застосування тактичної ядерної зброї
насправді не змінить ситуації для Росії
на полі бою
українці уже перемогли у війні
четвертого покоління
Росія більше не може захопити значні
території швидше за все вона втратить
багато якщо не все з того що захопила з
24 лютого за вашою рекомендацією Україні
варто в певний момент приєднатися до
НАТО Я думаю що цей момент наближається
президент Зеленський має рацію війна
закінчиться за столом переговорів
з постійний гість на ДВ чотиризірковий
генерал служив в раку та Афганістані був
головою ЦРУ і пішов у відставку у 2012
році Для мене велика честь поговорити з
ним сьогодні про війну в Україні та
глобальні наслідки у таки переломний
момент
генерали петреус радник президента США з
національної безпеки GX Салліван
нещодавно сказав я цитую що на Росію
чекають катастрофічні наслідки якщо воно
застосує ядерну зброю в Україні якими
будуть наслідки
коли я це почув то був відверто кажучи
задоволений тому що це вказує на те що
США і очевидно наші союзники обдумали це
питання і що важливо повідомили Росії що
застосування ядерної зброї призведе до
катастрофічної для неї відповіді вона як
я припускаю включатиме удари
по-російських силах в Україні та на
Чорному морі І це я цілком упевнений
буде дійсно нищівним ударом по
російських силах не забуваємо також яку
ціну платить Володимир Путін і що
втрачає він перебуває у безвихідному
становищі але застосування тактичної
ядерної зброї насправді не змінить
ситуації для Росії на полі бою це буде
звісно нищівний удар на тій ділянці фро
де ядерну зброю буде застосовано але це
не змінить ту реальність в якій
опинилася Росія А це новий розвиток
подій зумовлений українським успішним
наступом за ним стоїть той факт що
українці уже перемогли у війні
четвертого покоління у сучасному
розумінні українці провели мобілізацію
від самого початку І тепер у цієї країни
населення якої становить менше третини
населення Росії набагато більша за
чисельністю армія вона оснащена набагато
краще адже отримала військової допомоги
на суму понад 15 мільярдів доларів лише
від США нарахуючи союзників і зараз
українська армія надзвичайно ефективно
діє на полі бою Росія нічого не може
вдіяти щоб змінити цю ситуацію
Олена Генерала деякі люди кажуть що саме
через те що Путін може бути у
безвихідному становищі як ви казали може
вимірність того що він застосує ядерну
зброю чи вважаєте ви цей імовірними що
це означає
яка можливість безумовно існує і до
цього потрібно ставитись дуже серйозно Я
не думаю що це настільки ймовірно Але
знову ж таки до чогось настільки
небезпечного та Жахливого потрібно
ставитися серйозно цілком очевидно як
зазначив Джейк Салліван що ми ставимося
до цього серйозно І що ще важливіше Ми
спілкуємося з Росією та її керівництвом
доносимо В загальних рисах якою буде
відповідь щоб стримати їх відмовити від
ухвалення цього рішення це ще більше
згуртує Україну проти Росії ще більше
згуртує НАТО проти Росії це призведе до
додаткових дуже і дуже жорстких санкцій
фінансових економічних персональних це
може стати моментом коли Росію нарешті
оголосять спонсором тероризму Можливо
навіть винною у воєнних злочинах
проти Путіна висунуть звинувачення Я
думаю що це дозволить заходу проявити
рішучість до того ж так звана частково
мобілізація вже призвела до демонстрації
та різноманітних заворушень по всій
Росії
має те що у його країні така реакція на
мобілізацію для Володимира Путіна
Звісно це викликало демонстрації в Росії
таких масштабів яких ми не бачили вже
давно і він цього боявся Ось чому він
вагався так довго при цьому як ви знаєте
він до цього вже провів три часткові
мобілізації в певному сенсі перша була
доторгнення для навчань і підготовки
потім ще одна а потім і остання яка
здалася мені просто безглуздою по суті
це була вимога до кожного регіону у
складі Російської Федерації надати по
батальйону солдатів так не створюються
навчені оснащені організовані згуртовані
з гарним керівництвом бо й здатні
частини це те що ми робили під час війни
у часи на йогострішої потреби коли кожне
місто створювало власне Ополчення але
так не створюється сучасні боєздатні
збройні сили так він перебуває в
дуже-дуже серйозній і вкрай відчайдушній
ситуації Я не знаю наскільки люди
розуміють що в нього вже немає виходу з
цієї ситуації якщо виходити з того що
США та інші країни НАТО та заходу
продовжуватимуть надавати потужну
військову підтримку яку ми надаємо
Україні Я хотіла б поставити питання про
так звані референдуми Отже країни
Великої сімки вже заявили що не визнають
результатів так званих референдумів на
окупованих територіях України як це
вплине на військову стратегію
з українського боку відверто кажучи ніяк
Україна не має наміру визнавати
окуповані території частиною Росії
зокрема і ті які було захоплено в 2014
році
Україна вже завдала ударів і провела
операції проти російських сил у Криму І
на це не було жодної помітної відповіді
з боку Росії що це були удари по їхній
території чи щось таке я думаю що
реальна причина чому Путін хоче
завершити свою анекцію зараз це початок
щорічного осіннього призову до армії в
Росії Якщо тепер ці території будуть
частиною Росії то вони можуть спробувати
зібрати чоловіків призивного віку у цих
так званих нових російських республіках
або як вони там ще їх назвуть але це не
допоможе створити боєздатні добре
навчені оснащені організовані сили це
збере більше тіл але тіла - це не спосіб
боротьби з боєздатними українськими
силами які стають оснащеними і
професійнимис допоможіть мені зрозуміти
дискусію про танки Німеччину постійно
жор відмову постачати танки а якщо до
Франції та Великобританії
леопард-2 - це чудовий танк Люди купують
його тому що це чудовий танк коли
йдеться про бойовий танк М1 який
виробляється у США то він має проблему
Він дуже важкий його важко обслуговувати
щодо цього чудовиська вагою 70 тонн є
серйозні сумніви це по суті реактивний
двигун оточений важкою бронею з
величезною гарматою це півтори тисячі
кінських сил по суті це реактивна
турбіна це не традиційний дизельний
двигун у підрозділах під моїм
командуванням у бою було багато М1 Я
можу сказати що вимоги до їхнього
обслуговування величезні треба усі види
діагностики дуже висококваліфіковані
техніки механіки і все дуже важке
набагато важче ніж для будь-яких інших
танків у світі тому треба мати не лише
сам так М1
але й цілитех пар для його
обслуговування якщо танк зламається у
східній частині країни його треба
доставити назад до Польщі на ремонт
також потрібен спеціальний транспортний
засіб який зможе перевести 70 тонни танк
на велику відстань чи витримують мости
чи витримують дороги ось про такі
проблеми йдеться Я думаю що до М1
цікаво що Німеччина хоче щоб спочатку
США надали кілька машин щоб це
підтвердилося а потім Берлін міг би
надати свої Мені здається що леопард
буде простіше обслуговувати
про Німеччину якби ви зустрілися з
канцлером Німеччини олафом шульцем ви
сказали б йому надішліть кілька
леопардів Це було б вашої рекомендацією
я б ніколи не розкрив те що сказав би
політичному лідеру Хоча є чотиризірковий
генерал у відставці тоді Дозвольте мені
поставити питання по-іншому чи повинна
Німеччина відправити леопарди до України
Я хотів би побачити насамперед щоб
передали усі т-72 та 64 та 80 Які ще
можуть залишатися в арсеналах країн НАТО
більшість із них уже надали Україні але
можливо не всі українці знають як ними
керувати обслуговувати ремонтувати їх
мають боєприпаси для них уже потім можна
надавати леопарди м1 і все що є на мою
думку це правильний порядок дій До речі
я думаю не буде помилкою сказати що
зараз Україна має набагато більше танків
ніж було на початку війни бо вона
захопила приблизно третину або і більшу
російських машин Я не хочу занадто довго
зупинятися на цьому конкретному питанні
тому що можна почати забувати наскільки
величезною була надана допомога
Дозвольте мені навести вам Лише кілька
цифр лише з важкої артилерії лише
Сполучені Штати надали
126-150-міліметрових гаубиць це важкі
артилерійські знаряддя також надана
спеціальна техніка для їхнього
перевезення тому що без неї гідравлика
працює не так добре Також ми надали 750
тисяч артилерійських снарядів тільки для
цієї системи лише від 40 до 45 снарядів
поміщаються на 5 тонну вантажівку тож
порахуйте Та усвідомте скільки випадків
тисяч вантажівок має проїхати від
кордону з Польщею на Схід чи південь
лише для того щоб доставити їх до
артилерійських установок це дає уявлення
про те наскільки великі ці цифри навіть
для мене як для людини яка будучи
двозірковим генералом вистріляла не мало
артилерійських снарядів і ракет ці цифри
просто приголомшливі так Звісно це
зовсім інша війна але те що було надано
просто неймовірне снаряди ракети рсзв
які ми надали настільки точні що можуть
влучити В обідній стіл ці снаряди
коштують більше 100 тисяч доларів за
штуку і я думаю ми надали близько тисячі
таких снарядів для артилерії і приблизно
стільки ж для рсзв це лише частина тому
що їхня вартість величезна а наші власні
арсенали Не такий вже і великі
чого Україна зараз найбільше потребує
Я думаю що варто наголосити на
додатковій протиповітряній обороні це
проблема яка все ще дуже серйозно для
України Росія більше не може захопити
значні території швидше за все вона
втратить багато якщо не все з того що
захопила з 24 лютого хоча цьому і
передуватимуть жорсткі бої але те що
Росія може робити і робить це завдавати
по суті каральних ударів вони можуть
карати Україну ракетами Та снарями це
вони і роблять ціляться у цивільну
інфраструктуру руйнують лінії
електропередач електростанцій навіть
лікарні водопостачання усе щоб зробити
складнішим життя українців у районах
досяжності цих ракет звісно Росія має
певну зброю деяку дуже і дуже далекого
радіусу дій тож така сувора реальність
для України та її керівництва точно так
само як для Путіна сувора реальність
полягає у тому що він програ війну
четвертого покоління і наслідки цього
полягають у тому що його армія втратить
більшу частину якщо не все з того що
вони захопили після 24 лютого
за вашою рекомендацією Україні варто в
певний момент приєднатися до НАТО
Я думаю що цей момент наближається Я
думаю що це урок для нас ми переймалися
про реакцію Москви чутливість Кремля до
того що Україна може стати частиною
заходу НАТО ЄС ми ставилися до цього
дуже обережно наслідки цього не дуже
добрі і ми не можемо допустити
повторення такої ситуації варто також
пам'ятати що для відновлення України для
плану на зразок плану Маршала Україна
повинна отримати гарантії безпеки без
гарантії безпеки відновлення не вдасться
неможливо буде залучити зовнішніх
інвесторів згадаємо найважливішим
внеском США у відновлення європейських
країн після Другої світо Війни було на
фінансування плану Маршала яким би
важливим воно не було не зрозуміти мене
неправильно головними були гарантії
безпеки з боку США безперечно підтримка
з боку Сполучених Штатів з боку
президента байдена досі була дуже
великою чи зміниться це у зв'язку з
проміжними виборами чи можливим
результатом проміжних виборів
ні я думаю дуже важливо розуміти що на
капітолійському пагорбі серед найбільших
прихильників підтримки України лідер
меншості у сенаті сенатор міч макконел
провідний голос у цьому питанні звісно
разом із лідером більшості але абсолютно
ясно що існує сильна двопартійна
підтримка думаю що ми побачимо навіть
посилення підтримки ходять чутки що
можливо санатор лінза і Грем
відстоюватиме Цю пропозицію Це ще один
дуже сильний прихильник політики Білого
дому щодо України звісно хотілося б щоб
робилося більше Але знову ж таки є дуже
си підтримка в сенаті а також у палаті
представників у партіях меншості які
підтримують Білий дім тому я не думаю що
проміжні вибори вплинуть на ситуацію
буде достатньо підтримки незалежно від
того за тим більшість із огляду на те що
Президент Байден все що у Білому домі
чи є розуміння Як довго може тривати Ця
війна
є багато факторів один із них за яким я
стежу найбільш уважно пов'язаний із
моральним духом росіян окремі солдати
дрібні підрозділи великі частини чи вони
здаються розпадаються зникають Ця зима
буде суворішою для російських солдатів
ніж для українців для українців
перебувають на своїй власній землі
довкола них населення яке робить усе
можливе щоб їх підтримати росіяни
перебувають у регіонах де населення
ненавидить їх вони окупанти вони
принесли з собою жахливе насильство та
руйнування на підконтрольних їм
територіях Також ми бачимо все активніші
дії партизанів йде Повстанська війна
тероризм за лінією фронту
росіяни навіть не впевнені за що їх
змушують воювати а українці борються
свідомо це війна за їхню незалежність а
для росіян це загарбницька війна і все
частіше росіяни виступатимуть зокрема на
вулицях проти того що робить Путін і в
міру того як це триватиме російський
солдати замисляться Чи хочуть вони бути
останніми хто загине у цій війні я
просто не бачу як частково мобілізація
може створити ефективний бойовий
потенціал Ані Зараз Ані в найближчому
майбутньому У той час як це усвідомлення
приходитиме до російських солдатів Як
довго вони зможуть продовжувати
ефективно воювати чи будуть їхні
підрозділи розпадатися дуже важко
відчути це спостерігаючи здалеку це
важко оцінити навіть на полі бою я брав
участь у деяких боях під час битви за
Багдад де раптово ворог поступився після
кіль 10 днів важких боїв якщо озирнутися
назад то там не було жодного конкретного
каталізатора чи діє які б свідчили що це
станеться вони досягли межі фізичної чи
моральної коли настане ця точка дуже
важко сказати поки кульмінація
наближається і українці досягають
подальших успіхів я думаю що в якийсь
момент знову розпочнуться переговори бо
врешті-решт президент Зеленський має
рацію війна закінчиться за столом
переговорів Але як я вже говорив
критично важливим елементом перемовин На
мою думку мають бути гарантії безпеки з
боку заходу
генерали петреус Дякую вам чекатиму на
можливість продовжити цю розмову дякую
вам